SPEAKER: Without
any further ado,
I would invite Rachael
to come and share
all the wisdom with us
from her book today.
RACHAEL O'MEARA: Hi, everybody.
Welcome.
This is so weird.
I'm usually the one who's
hosting people at Google
as a person who helps authors
have their message come out
in the world.
And today is quite the occasion,
because I actually have
a book that I get to share.
And today is the official
world premiere, woo!
I get to say that because it's
actually launching officially
today.
So you guys in the room and on
the video are like the first
people in the whole world of
7 billion people to hear about
"."
So it's pretty exciting.
I'm really glad you came today.
And I'm excited to
share my message.
I'm excited to share more
about what's happening
with "Pause," my story.
I work at Google in
San Francisco usually.
So I'm on a team for the sales
world underneath the platforms
team called the PDC.
Shout out to them.
Hi, I know you're on video.
And I've been at Google
for nine years, which
is quite extraordinary
in itself,
and I was at
DoubleClick before that.
So that's all in the book.
I'm not going to get
into it too much.
But that's a little bit
about me to get started.
And a couple of things
as we go along here.
So I just put this presentation
together last night.
I was like, should
I have some slides?
And knowing I've hosted
authors before, I
was kind of thinking
like, well, I
guess for the visual
learners, that'd be good.
And then I put
some sides together
and realized I didn't
have anything on it
other than pictures.
So this will be fun.
I'm excited to share.
And all of the quotes
that you'll see today
are from and in "Pause."
And they're basically quotes
that really spoke to me,
quotes that I thought
were inspirational
or really helped
resonate a message.
And then I put some
quotes up there, too.
So I have a couple
of quotes, and I
have these on my Facebook
page, and just enjoy
the pictures and the quotes,
and I think they're great.
So today my whole objective
and my vision is to have fun.
I'm just really excited
to be here, obviously.
And I'll be talking a lot, but
I also want to answer questions.
So we'll leave time for that.
Then we'll talk some more,
and you can get your book.
So there's books
available outside.
Glen's here from Books Inc,
and I put a link on the slides
so you can see where to
get them if you're online
or want to get a
book somewhere else.
And just a note
before we jump in--
this is not a
Google presentation.
And I get to say that
because I'm a Googler.
And I also want to just
have some fun today.
So no templates, just all
quotes, so have some fun,
and really hopefully
sharing my message.
And for those of you
who are not in the room,
there's like 100
balloons in here,
and you've got a couple
here you can see.
But I'm pretty excited, because
I didn't put the balloons here,
but it seems like
they were meant to be.
So whoever left the
balloons, thank you.
I feel very festive with
the Googly balloons here.
So I saw this meme and I had to
put it into the deck yesterday,
because this is what
I feel like right now.
Well, OK, I'm not
a stormtrooper,
but two of my worlds
colliding here.
I love muppets.
I love "Star Wars."
But really it's like
my worlds are colliding
where I'm a Googler
and I'm giving a talk,
and "Pause" is out in the world.
So it's like shit gets real.
And I blocked that out as a
word-- but I just said it,
so it doesn't really matter--
so that the NC-17 people don't
veto my presentation out there.
But yeah, this is a really
interesting time for me.
And it just feels good.
And it's like, OK, the
worlds are merging.
I've had "Pause."
I've been writing
it for five years.
And then I've got Google.
I've been here for nine years.
And it's like they've
been separate,
sometimes weaving in and
out, but now it's like, boom,
they're together.
So it's a really cool thing.
And I like that
they're together.
And I don't know about muppets
in stormtrooper outfits,
but you can send me
feedback on that.
I did not create that meme.
It was on the web.
So here's what we're
going to talk about today.
We'll be talking about
my story, and then I've
got some parts of what
we'll talk about today
that are in "Pause."
We'll even do a demo.
And I kind of use the
demo as a joke as a term,
but the idea is that I
want to experience pausing
and take you through
something today
that I think will be
helpful for all of us.
And just a really
quick experiential--
I'm all about the
experience of what
you can do to intentionally
shift your behavior.
So we'll talk about
the five signs you need
to pause, the types of pauses.
I'll take you through what
I think mental flossing is,
and this technique I
came up with called
TASERing for your
limiting beliefs,
and why all this matters.
Why do we need to pause?
Maybe you know already, but I'll
give you my version of that.
And then keeping it Googly--
that's for all the Googlers--
next steps and AIs,
because we're so
action oriented here.
Really what that means is
takeaways or something else.
So my story-- hopefully you can
read the quotes up here, too.
So a lot of everything
I'm going to say
is pretty much in "Pause" today.
So what I want to share the
most is basically my story.
So back in 2011, I'd been
at Google about five years.
And I was in a role in
the gTech community, which
is our internal customer service
team, and I wasn't doing well.
For whatever reason things
weren't going great.
I was kind of in this rut.
I was burning out.
And how many people,
just show of hands,
has ever felt that way?
Like in a burned out
state, or just rotten,
you can't figure
out what's going on?
You're like, what's going on?
I feel like I'm doing
OK, but for whatever
reason things aren't working.
So in the room a lot
of hands were raised.
And the idea is that--
I wasn't about effort.
I really wanted to do well, but
I was kind of new in the role.
About six months in, managing
a team of customer support
people, and things
weren't going great.
I was getting feedback that my
performance wasn't doing well.
My performance was suffering.
And I actually had this whole
list of things to improve upon,
which were very tactical
and helpful for me.
So I had this plan in place.
Hold on a second, I
got some water here.
And I didn't know what to do.
Everything I was trying,
I was like, today
is going to be different.
I'm going to go in there and
my meetings will be different.
I'll communicate effectively.
I'll be more present.
I'll have other things to share.
And to whatever effect, I
just kept feeling burned out.
And my mental state was one
where I was feeding myself
stories that things
would never get better,
or that I wasn't doing well.
Tapes, I call them,
played in my mind.
Like, Rachael,
there you go again.
Why are you even bothering?
Or why don't you
just quit today?
Or you're a failure.
So all of this was going on.
And I reached a point where
my manager was basically like,
this isn't a fit for you.
And that is one of
the signs, by the way,
that you need a pause
when someone tells you
it's not working out.
So I was faced with a choice.
And I went home that day,
it was a Friday afternoon.
And I went home riding my
bike home in San Francisco.
And I was like, what do I do?
Do I quit?
Do I just keep trying?
And I think I like
Google, but I don't know.
And my mental state
just wasn't in a place
to really think clearly.
So what happened
was I got on a Skype
that weekend with a couple
girlfriends and someone
suggested that Google might have
this leave of absence program.
And I was like,
oh, that's right.
They do have a leave
of absence program.
I should look into that.
And so that weekend
I spent researching
the leave of absence
program and made a case
to take three months
of unpaid leave.
And so Monday morning
I came back to Google,
and I made the
request to my manager.
And she was as
surprised as I had
been to learn that
we had a program,
or that that would be a good
idea, and said, that sounds
like a good fit as well.
Let me take it to HR and see
if we can get it approved.
And what happened was
I got it approved.
And this was the
beginning of what
I would call my pause, which I
define as any intentional shift
in behavior.
So it doesn't mean it's a
long-term break like I had,
but it can be.
So I ended up taking three
months of unpaid leave in--
it was the summer of 2011.
And the terms were that I would
come back to Google, ideally,
but I wouldn't be
in the same role,
and I would hire a
replacement when I returned.
And so all of that happened
before I left, which was great.
I had about a month
and a half to do that.
And I didn't know if I
was going to come back
to Google, actually.
And I just really
had no idea, other
than I knew I needed to
move into a new state,
and I couldn't continue
as things were going.
It wasn't effective for me,
and I really wasn't happy.
So that's a little bit
about the background
of how this all happened.
And looking back now, five years
ago, if I had known any of this
would have been
the case, and this
would be how things
have turned out,
I would have been
really surprised.
Because I was just
about the end of my rope
and not sure what to
do and what happened.
So that three months of
unpaid break was me unwinding.
It was me kind of reassessing
where I wanted to go.
I didn't know if I was
on the right career path.
I didn't know if I
should stay at Google,
but I was pretty
sure I liked Google.
And it was really this
unknown time for me.
And it was the first time
in my life for a few things.
And one of them was to
really be with myself.
Meaning, looking at my
career, looking at who I was,
and being like, is
this what I want?
Is this the path that
I want to stay on?
And so that led to a whole
other bunch of discoveries--
many, many discoveries
since then.
So the good news is that was
the opening, I'll call it,
kind of the first doorway
that I walked through.
And then that led
to a lot more that
ended up happening
as I did return
to Google in September of 2011.
And I looked for
a new role, and I
got a new job, which is the job
that I have now and the team
that I'm on now.
So that is my story
in a nutshell.
And so since then I came
back to Google, and maybe
about eight months
later, I started
thinking about wanting
to share my story.
And I didn't really
know how to do it,
but I started to
write a document which
later became the book.
And one of the first
themes I captured
was, how do you know if you need
this so-called break, or pause,
or a shift in behavior?
So I came up with
these five signs.
And each of these
signs, the idea
is that you might have one
of these happen to you,
or maybe all five of them
have happened to you.
In my case-- and I'll go
over them in a second--
I think I had all of
them happen to me.
So I kind of did the tally and
decided that, yeah, this is
a good way that you can pause.
So I'll walk you
through the five signs.
The first sign is you
used to love your job,
and now you loathe it.
Pretty self-explanatory, right?
I thought so.
So that was my case.
I used to really enjoy being
at my work in the day to day.
And all of a sudden
it was like, just
things weren't going
great, and I didn't even
want to be there anymore.
So that was the first sign.
Second sign, you
know need a break,
and you used to love your job,
and then your manager tells you
it's not working out.
I mentioned that this
one was also experienced.
So this might come as a
really direct message.
It could be something
you hear in the hallway.
It might be something
a coworker says to you,
or even a friend who's like,
you sound miserable there.
What's going on?
But in my case, I call it
the proverbial pink slip.
But basically, it was my manager
having a heart to heart with me
and saying this really
wasn't a fit for me.
And at the end looking
back, and even at the time,
I knew she was right.
So that's the second sign.
And the third sign is that you
have a technology intervention
from a friend, or someone
who really cares about you,
or even just knows you
as an acquaintance.
And we can all probably
identify with that one.
The idea is that if you're
on your phone all the time,
or you're missing
out on relationships
because you're tethered
to a laptop, and I was.
I was tethered to
my email, and I
would be checking it
like Sunday afternoons
to get ready for Monday.
That's a sign.
And if it's interfering
with how you
are with other people, or
your family, or other ways
that you want to
be in the world,
then that's a telltale
sign, in my opinion.
And the fourth sign is
that there is an overcoming
challenge that you face.
And this could be something
like a health challenge,
or a family member
that has become someone
that you need to be paying more
attention to, or ill, or sick,
or something like that.
Could be a layoff.
But basically in
adversity-- something
that you're faced
with that isn't
exactly what you'd planned,
and you got to deal with it.
So who can relate to that one?
Yeah, I think that one's
a pretty common one.
And then the last one is
that there is actually
an opportunity that comes up.
So this one can be in
multiple different ways.
But the idea is that there might
be some nagging opportunity
that you want to pursue,
or an idea that you
have to follow through with.
It might be something as easy as
a class that you want to take.
But it could be something like
a weekend with a friend who's
been wanting you to go for
years on a certain trip.
It might be an idea to have
a business that you start.
It could be a whole bunch
of different things.
And so the idea is
that, again, this
is an intentional
shift in behavior.
So if this is something
that's going on,
and you kind of think about
things, more than even a couple
of times a day, then
that might be a good sign
to know that a
pause is something
that could be helpful.
So those are the five
signs, and I kind of
went through them quickly.
But the idea is if you
go through each one
of those mentally
and give yourself
a point for any of those,
if you score a one, that
means you're doing pretty well.
But if you have maybe even
more than two, two or more,
chances are a pause would
be a really good idea.
And the good news is
everyone can pause.
And that's a big
message I have today
is that it's not about
this long extended break.
This is literally about
being intentional and being
with yourself to know what
you need to do for you.
Whatever works for you.
Whether you've got resources
like time, or money,
or activity, and
all of those are
levers that you can play with.
So there's many different
types of pauses to have,
and I mention this right there.
So they can go from
a simple thing,
like following your breath.
And how many people here do any
types of mindful meditation?
Or just-- yeah, a lot
of hands are going up--
ways that you can practice
being in the moment
and being with yourself?
And that might mean a walk where
you're being really mindful
around the block.
Or it might be a
conversation that's
more engaging than what
you would normally do.
Having a deeper
level of engagement
with a person other
than yourself.
All of those I consider pauses.
Again, it's an intentional
shift in behavior.
Other ideas for pausing,
so digital device pausing.
So this is a big one.
So digital device
pausing, if there
is an idea where you think
you're on your phone too much,
or you're checking it when
you go to the bathroom,
or you are sleeping with
it under your pillow,
things like that.
I think they are
actually real cases.
And the idea is that
that's OK, but make sure
that the boundaries that you
have for those digital devices
are in service to you.
So is it taking
you away from being
with others or the moment?
Or you're not really, fully
present in one activity?
So digital device pauses
are a big, big deal.
And more than ever,
they matter, and you
can experiment with that.
So it might be setting
up a rule for yourself.
I'm a big fan of rules so you
can get into some boundaries
and creating things.
So not checking your
phone after 9:00 PM,
or staying off social
media on the weekends.
That's one I actually recently
started, and I liked it.
Although, it won't be
happening right now.
Then you can expand from there.
So there's other
ways you can pause.
And if you have time to
do it for more than a day,
or it could be a
weekend, or a week.
And then there's
the extended pauses,
like I had for three
months, which is amazing.
And not a lot of us have
that luxury, I know.
There's actually a
statistic from the Society
of Human Resource Management
that says about 14% to 15%
of global companies allow
for unpaid or paid breaks.
There's only 4% of companies
that have paid breaks.
So knowing that's not an
option for a lot of us,
my point is that you can
pause and integrate that
through your life.
It doesn't have to be
a long type of break
that you need to take.
And then the other type of
pause is the unintended pause.
So this is when
you get laid off,
or you have this huge shift that
you weren't planning to have.
And I think a lot of
us go through this
at some point in our life.
But the idea is that it's
easy to get stuck in a victim
mentality, or maybe just sulk
around, and now say, well,
now what?
But the actual idea is if
you are intentional about it,
that time is an amazing gift
that you can have for yourself
and choose how you want
to live differently.
It might be during that time,
or it might be shifting careers,
or it might be looking
for something that really
does align with you more.
So those are all types
of pauses and great ways
to integrate intentional
shifts in behavior.
And there's even a thing
called mini pauses.
I write about these in the book
from Dr. David King Keller.
He did a PhD on pausing, which
is pretty cool, in my opinion.
And there's a couple
exercises in the book,
and maybe we'll do one
of those in the demo.
Hey, look at that.
So next we're going to
try one of these out.
And we're a little limited,
because we're here in the room.
But if you're with
me in the room,
go ahead and just get
comfortable, and maybe
put your feet on the floor.
If you're not in the room
and you're watching this
at home or at work,
do the same thing,
follow along, and try
how this is for you.
So we're going to try
one of these micro pauses
from Dr. Keller.
And what we're going to do is--
I think it's called
the two palm pause.
So go ahead and
I'll face this way.
Put your two hands up about
six inches from your nose
and notice your hands.
Scanning them for the
texture, lines, color.
Notice your breathing.
And go ahead and
put your hands down.
How did that feel?
Did anyone notice a shift?
I did.
Yeah, so that's literally a 30
second pause that you can take.
And it really does wonders.
And then there's a couple
more like that that he has.
And then my favorite go-to
is just following the breath.
So you can go ahead
and put one hand
on your belly or your
stomach, go ahead
and inhale, [INHALES]
and exhale, [EXHALES]
and do it one more time.
Inhale through your nose,
[INHALES] [EXHALES] Exhale
your mouth.
And you can close your
eyes or open your eyes.
We'll take one more.
[INHALES] [EXHALES] Go
ahead and open your eyes.
So that's the
daily breath pause.
And again, that took
maybe 30 seconds.
And every chapter I have
exercises that you can try that
are related to pausing
or journaling exercises.
And the idea is that you
can increase that time,
or go up to 10 breaths
and count to 10,
and increase your
skill level in it.
It's actually more like
lifting weights at the gym.
So those are some really
quick demos that we just did.
But the idea is that, again,
it's about what works for you.
So as you decide and think
about what kind of pausing
would resonate with you-- it
might be things to do outside.
It might be journaling.
It might be these micro pauses.
It could be a solo
retreat for yourself,
as scary as that might sound.
All of those are
options, and I encourage
you to look at
what works for you
and see what would really
resonate and then try it.
Because the idea is that
everything is an experiment.
And in the book, I talk about
Dr. Carol Dweck and her growth
mindset research.
Has anyone heard of
Carol and her research?
I think most of us here have.
Yeah.
So the idea is that if
you bring your curiosity,
and an open mind, and that
childlike understanding
of what can I learn here--
learning and growing?
Then you will likely
learn or grow.
And if you have that fixed
mindset, it's not so easy,
and you kind of shut
down and are closed off.
So I invite you to bring your--
I call it the pause
mindset, as well.
So it's this idea of being open
to ideas and then acting on it.
So those are a couple of
demos, and they're in the book
as well.
Another idea that
I have for pausing,
and I talk a lot about
this, where we've got
limiting beliefs in our world.
And a lot of what I've been
studying at the Wright Graduate
University in Chicago, the
Wright Foundation with Bob
and Judith Wright is about
what are our belief systems,
and where do we operate from?
Because each of us have these
in our minds, in our heads,
and it's how we see the world.
So this technique I call
the TASER technique,
and I think of it like mental
flossing is kind of the overlay
here.
Where think of
like dental floss,
and you're kind of going
in between your teeth.
I'm a big flosser.
I don't know if we got
any self-devoted flossers
in the room.
But if you are in
there and getting
in between the
grooves in your teeth,
you're cleaning out the gunk.
And we can't really do
that with our minds,
because they're obviously
not accessible that way.
God knows what would happen.
But you can think
of it metaphorically
and know that when you
are mental flossing,
you can have the same effect.
So that means being conscious
about what your thoughts are
and what your beliefs are.
So TASERing is an
acronym, and it
stands for Tune In, Acknowledge,
Shift, Express, and Repeat.
So the idea is that
any belief that you
have that you don't
think is accurate--
so we'll do this together.
So go ahead and think
about so far your day,
and maybe you've got an hour
that you've been in traffic,
or you're late and
you potentially
had an argument with a
partner, or anything like that.
Go ahead and what
was the thought that
went through your mind
about you as a belief?
In my case, I was
preparing for the talk.
I was looking at
emails for my job.
And I was like, why am I
looking at emails for my job?
I'm not prepared.
I'm not enough.
That's a big one for me.
So that's a belief that I have--
I'm not enough.
So if I were to take and
apply the TASER technique--
and think of TASER like a
zap, like these stun guns.
So T is Tune In.
So, oh, OK, so my belief
is I'm not enough.
OK, well, that's great.
Acknowledge it.
OK.
So that's my belief.
And I'm not judging it.
I'm not like, there I go again.
There's not really
a critic there,
but it's just acknowledging
that and simply knowing that.
And shift is, what
is the new belief
that I would want to replace
that with in this outdated
system I have in my mental map?
So my shift would be
pretty much the opposite
of what my belief is,
which would be, what is it?
I am enough.
Yeah, it's really simple.
It's just pretty
much the opposite.
And it's about me.
It's not about somebody else.
It's about me.
So, oh, I am enough.
And then expressing
that is either
saying it under my breath.
It depends on where I am,
but I could say it out loud.
I am enough.
Like I am right now,
so this is pretty cool.
Or I could be writing
it in a journal.
And the idea is
when we express, we
are creating new mental
maps in our brains.
The neuroplasticity is there
so that we can change the way
that our minds are working.
And over time as we
repeat this, the R,
we're creating new
ways of thinking,
and new ways of
being, and new habits.
And it's not going
to happen overnight.
This is a long haul process.
But the idea is that if we
actually become conscious
of this-- and this is
one tool you can use--
then you might actually
be able to shift
some things around that are
in better service to you.
And so that you end up
feeling more satisfied or not
as in that mental
mind tailspin like I
did when I was in
my burnout phase
at Google a couple of years ago.
So that's one tool.
And I invite you all to give it
a try today at least one more
time.
OK.
So we're not done
yet, but I wanted
to just go ahead and actually
answer any questions that you
have that have come up so far.
AUDIENCE: So thank you
for mentioning those five
identifiers of when
someone needs a pause
and then doing a pause.
So should there be a
pre-conception before the pause
that what should one
achieve after that,
or should it be open ended?
RACHAEL O'MEARA: OK.
So the question is,
should it be open ended?
It's a good question,
because I think
that's the first
question we all have.
We want to jump to, well,
what does this mean?
And do I need to
have it figured out?
And I know that was my question.
And I didn't, and I was kind
of freaking out about it,
because I didn't know
what would happen.
So I call this
the pause paradox.
And the idea is that we're
taking a step back to be,
and not be so busy, or do.
And our human mind
type A thinker brains
want to figure everything
out really quickly.
And so the paradox is you've
got all this time, why would
you not want to figure
it out and think
about things as you reflect
or you shift your behavior?
And my thought is I think it's
good to have broad strokes.
I think it's healthy
and a really good thing
to do to set your intention.
So what do I want to have
come out of my weekend
as I reflect on my career shift?
Or what are the three
things I feel like I
want to do more with my family?
And that's intention.
Those are changes.
So I think broad
strokes are really good.
And then I think the
little things, like, well,
how am I going to do that?
What are the 10 things
I need to do today
to make sure that I stay on
track are maybe not as good.
And again, it's an experiment.
So I think it will be
different for all of us.
And I think it depends
on what works for you.
But I invite all of you
to actually not plan,
because I think it's easy for
our brains to get into that.
And the whole gift and
the magic of a pause
is maybe being out
of your comfort zone
and not controlling everything.
Potentially it could be to let
the magic happen, as I say.
Like being out of your
comfort zone is scary.
And we have a lot of
fear in our own heads
that prevent us from wanting to
do that based on just safety,
and the psychological
safety of wanting
to know what's comfortable.
So when we start
letting things just go,
we kind of want to go into a
panic mode or change things.
But in general, I'd say,
well, why not just be and not
have a big plan?
And if you set your
intention and know
what you want out of it, I think
that's a really good way to go.
Because you kind of have a
guide that lay on the horizon,
but you don't have to have
all the minutia steps.
And then that's the routine that
we know, and where most of us
are used to.
So you're going to really
change a whole bunch
if you're in that
routine and wanting
to stick to what you know.
But I think it's a experiment.
Good question.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: You said that you
were working pretty hard putting
in all the efforts
before you took a pause,
and after pause you
said that you are happy
and you are satisfied.
So what were the key things in
your day-to-day life changed?
What type of approaches
changed towards your work
that you felt the other way?
RACHAEL O'MEARA: Yeah, what
were the things that changed?
So in my case, I took
this three months break.
And I knew I needed
to take myself out
of the system, which
was work at the time,
and allow my self
some new space.
So I did that.
And what happened was
I learned a few things
about how to be present for me.
Meaning, how do I
engage with someone else
and really see them eye to
eye, like have eye contact,
and appreciate the
conversation I'm
having in the moment with them?
And I didn't really
do that before.
To be fully honest, I
think I just surface
level engaged with people.
And I didn't have that
presence, and so there wasn't
a lot of meaning there for me.
Meaning, I wasn't
getting satisfied.
I think I was settling
for conversations
that were OK and good.
And this was in my relationship.
This was with
friends and at work.
But when I took it
to a deeper level,
and really wanted
to be with someone,
and see someone eye
to eye, and be like,
wow, I'm really noticing I'm
enjoying this conversation.
I'm learning something
about this person.
That's pretty cool.
It allowed me to feel more.
And I think that
was a big shift.
I didn't know it at the time.
And since then, I've done
some personal development work
in emotional intelligence.
So I know now that
was what happened.
But I think it was
being more present.
Honestly, that was
like the simple answer.
And then I did a few
things on the break,
too, that helped me
align with my strengths.
So I took the strengths
finder assessment,
which is in the book from
Tom Rath and the Gallup poll
people.
And I aligned with
what my strengths were,
so I actually felt happier
because I was working.
And I decided to go into sales
because I actually just thought
that I would be better managing
relationships and creating
relationships.
And I was also asking my friends
what they thought I was good at
and similar messages
started appearing--
like you're a great networker,
you're a great communicator.
It actually was not
the same feedback
that I'd gotten in the job,
which was very affirming to me.
So a lot of it was
actually self-affirmation,
self-validated intimacy, which
is David Schnarch's term, which
I quote and cite in the book.
But it was about
feeling good for myself,
and I had never really
done that before in a level
that changed how I
thought about things.
So I think it was a
combination of things.
Essentially feeling
more present,
and then allowing myself
to be affirmed, and feeling
affirmed, and enjoying the
moments, and feeling happier.
Whether it was someone
I was talking to,
or the job that I was
really aligned with that
played to my strengths more.
So that's kind of what I think.
So what is the point?
Why are we here?
What does pausing
really lead us to?
And I think it's similar to
the more broader mindfulness
question of being more
present with myself.
But the idea is that if
I can shift my behavior--
so getting away from the
pause language a little bit--
if I'm just talking about
choosing to be different,
and that's all this really is.
This is my choice, your
choice, our choice to change.
And if I can actually not
have a knee-jerk reaction-- so
deciding to take that
three-month unpaid leave,
that was a long pause.
But if I just choose
to be different and act
in a different way,
taking some time,
the idea is that new
ideas might emerge,
new ways of being might emerge,
new thoughts might emerge.
And I can change my behavior to
align with what matters to me.
I'll say that again because
it's really important.
If you're out there and things
aren't really going great
for you, or you want
to change in some way--
maybe one of those
five signs happened,
maybe you're feeling an itch
to just do something different,
or you're not
feeling satisfied--
satisfied is a really
key part of this--
you can pause.
And shifting that behavior
can allow new things
to emerge for you, whether
it's ways of being,
or ways of behaving, or engaging
with others, or relationships,
career, all of that.
And you can lead a more
satisfied and meaningful life.
And my teachers in Chicago,
Judith and Bob Wright,
this is their huge
message and theme
that I continually
learn from them.
And if I'm with myself--
meaning I'm emotionally present.
I can feel my feelings.
I know I'm in joy,
or I'm in fear.
I'm in anger.
I'm in sadness.
I'm in hurt.
And I can just be with that.
And that's difficult.
It's not easy.
I'm able to be more with
others and feel more satisfied.
Because I know that I'm here,
and these beliefs are changing.
And I have-- I know I matter.
I know I'm good enough.
I am enough.
I'm loved.
I can connect.
And these are topics
called yearnings, which I
won't get into too much today.
But my mentor, Judith
Wright, this is her research.
But when we go and
satisfy these yearnings,
then we do lead more
meaningful and satisfied lives.
And a lot of the time,
we're so busy in our heads.
We are living, like I
historically was, from my neck
up.
We don't tune into
that, and we've
learned over time to
maybe shut it down or not
pay attention to it.
And that's OK.
But the idea is
that you probably
aren't going to
get too satisfied
or feel a lot to know what
really makes you come alive.
And isn't that why
we're all here?
Isn't that why we're
on this planet?
And not to just be kind
of chumming through life?
And I talk about
this in the book--
I have three types of people.
I kind of sum it
up this way where
there's pausers, sleepers,
and pause helpers, I think.
And so pausers are the folks who
choose to intentionally shift
their behavior.
And this can come in a
number of different ways.
There's sleepers.
So I think I had the
word zombie at first,
and I was like, that's
probably not a nice term.
So sleepers are folks I think
who sleepwalk through life.
And this was me.
Even though I was a
national rowing champion,
and I was a huge
achiever, I wasn't
on a level of really
being emotionally present.
And I'm probably being pretty
hard on myself right now,
but I take it with
a grain of salt.
So sleepers maybe wake
up and pause one day.
Or maybe there is
a pause helper.
So pause helper is the
third type of person
where they potentially get you.
If you tell them
you're taking a pause,
they're not going
to shut you down.
Or there might be
a way that they're
encouraging and supporting
you in whatever you're
go through in life.
And so I think
there's ways you can
transition between any three
of those groups for sure.
And maybe go back and forth
throughout your lifetime.
But the idea is that when you
can pause and intentionally
shift your behavior to generate
ways of being that are new,
or emotions that
come up that are new,
or new thoughts that you have.
That can shift your life
in a big way, like mine.
So my life has shifted, but
these are little changes
over time, as well.
They don't have to
be this long break.
So if you decide to turn
your phone off at 8:00 PM
every night, now you've
got another hour.
And that doesn't mean
you're on Netflix an hour.
You're like a lump on the couch.
But you're actually engaged
with meaningful conversation
with others.
Because I'm meeting
my connection needs,
and I'm feeling affirmed
and validated again.
Those things add up, and they
allow you to be more present
and feel more.
And again, this is all going
back to being more satisfied.
And if we're kind of floating
through life being a sleeper,
it's not so satisfying.
And it is on some level if
you want to rationalize that,
but think about what could
happen, or what could change.
What could change if you
decided to intentionally shift
your behavior?
And that's kind of
the whole point.
So that leads us
to a pause plan.
And the idea is that anyone
can create their own pause
plan that works for you.
And a pause plan is
really just what would you
want to do to start pausing?
What would you want
to intentionally shift
for your behavior?
It can be a little
small tweak in your day.
It could be looking at your
two palms for 30 seconds today.
It could be having
a conversation
that you've been wanting
to have for two years
and you've been putting off.
And the book is
filled with really
how you can decide
what works for you.
And I talk about
the pause dashboard,
which is three
levers that we all
have and we can kind of adjust.
So whether you've
got $1 million,
or $1, or zero dollars, or
all the time in the world,
or five seconds, the idea
is that you can create
a plan that works for you.
So the three levers are--
really the first one
is money, finances.
So if you wanted to
really dive in and take
this high-end type of pause,
you can, but you don't have to.
And pausing isn't about luxury
vacations, although it can be.
But it allows you to
think about what could you
do based on your budget?
And I actually have
a whole worksheet
on this if you wanted to look
at plugging in some numbers,
and it's on my site
and in the book.
And the next one is, we
did finances, so activity.
So what do you want to do?
And pausing isn't about the
quantity of time at all.
If you've heard that 100
times in different ways,
that's the case.
Pausing about the
quality of time,
and based on what
you'd want to do.
So this is where you
get to choose again
what you want to do.
So it could be that
walk in the park.
And ideally, you get out of
your comfort zone a little bit.
Maybe it's actually trying
to meditate if you've never
tried it, and decided
always that you
don't have time for it.
Well, guess what?
If you brought your
growth mindset,
maybe this is a curious thing
for you, and you can shift.
And we all have that power.
And then the third one is time.
So I talked a little
bit about this,
but time is really irrelevant.
It's about what works for you.
So between those
three levers, everyone
can come up with
what works for you.
And I think journaling's
a great tool.
It's also a way that
you can express,
and it also changes how
you think about ideas
when you put them on paper.
There's research on that,
and it's in the book.
So journaling can be
part of your pause plan.
It can involve other people.
And the idea is that--
how can you shift to lead
a more meaningful life?
And that's really
the name of the game.
It's not to be a better pauser,
although, that's probably
pretty nice, but it's really
about what can work for you.
So I hope all of you can
walk out of this room
or in this discussion,
and decide what you
could put into your pause plan.
And maybe just take a moment
right now with me kind
of going back into that
space, and close your eyes
if you want to.
Go ahead and take a breath,
[INHALES] [EXHALES] and ask
yourself, what would I do?
Who would I be if I had one
minute, five minutes, an hour,
days to pause?
Go ahead and open your eyes,
and that is the power of pause.
Thank you.
I'll take more questions
if we've got some.
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned journaling.
Are there any special
techniques within journaling
that you can relate that we can
use as part of our reflection?
RACHAEL O'MEARA: Yeah.
So the study that
is in "Pause," it's
also in the Search
Inside Yourself training.
There was some research done
that for two minutes a day
if you journal about an
emotional experience--
so you write in a
book literally how
you felt about
something that happened.
There's research that
shows that you actually
process that differently.
And now it's escaping
me, of course,
but it's actually leading
to being more in touch
with your feelings and changing
how you feel about things.
So it's a tool you
can use to harness
that emotional intelligence and
continue to build that skill.
But two minutes a day,
and this study, I think,
was over a series of weeks.
And the group that
they researched
found that they had--
I think it was-- a better sense
of overall happiness, something
to that effect.
I'm probably
butchering the study.
But yeah, it was
interesting to me.
Because two minutes
a day, I mean,
that's pretty easy to
come up with, right?
Whether it's in the
morning or night.
And if you actually
did that about how
you felt about
something, so like, oh,
such and such happened
to me, and I felt--
and name an emotion.
I felt happy, I
felt a lot of joy.
It could be gratitude.
But it might also be things that
weren't so pleasant, like, sad,
or really frustrated and angry.
And so the idea is
that you're activating
different parts of your
brain through writing,
and it's also activating
your emotional intelligence,
and therefore allowing yourself
to increase that skill.
And there's other
research too about writing
and how it operates
different parts of the brain.
And I've got a few of those
cited in "Pause," where
it enhances your
learning because it's
in different formats, whether
you're thinking or writing.
And it reinforces it.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
about your long pause,
and if there is anything that
you're really glad that you
did, any strategies
that you actually
did that changed
your perspective,
and also how you would
do it differently
if you did it again.
RACHAEL O'MEARA: Oh, boy.
So yes, there were things
that I did in my three months.
So back to the question
earlier, do I plan it all out,
or do I just do it?
And so I had a real
urge to travel.
I've always been a traveler.
I knew I could do
some crazy trip.
I want to go to
Argentina or something.
And I got kind of real
with myself and said,
is that really the best
thing for you right now?
So I actually chose
to not do things.
I chose to not travel.
I chose to be with myself,
which was kind of scary,
and just regroup a little bit.
So that decision I
thought helped me a lot.
And it was a choice that
I made to really not do
what I would normally do.
And this is that
comfort zone thing.
My comfort zone was to go out
on an adventure, because I
was pretty adventurous.
And I can do that,
and figure it all out.
Being with myself and
learning how I wasn't working,
and maybe my career was
a sham, and I didn't even
want to do this anymore
was really scary and not
in my comfort zone.
I didn't see it at the time,
but in hindsight that's
actually really what happened.
So I allowed myself, I gave
myself permission to do that.
And I knew that one of
the responsibilities
I had was knowing I may not
want to be here anymore.
I may want to switch
careers entirely.
I had this idea I
wanted to do bike tours.
And I did, actually, in
the fall of that year,
along with working at Google.
But I think it just helped
me allow myself some space
to come up with ideas.
And what would I do differently?
What would I do differently?
I think there were three things
that I did that I actually
really liked.
So I don't know, that's
a great question.
Maybe I'll think of something.
I'm sure there's some things
I could have done differently.
So one was choosing
not to travel,
but I did take a
couple of mini trips.
So I took one to see
my brother in Texas.
I went to Burning Man
for the first time, which
was a key part of my
pause, by the way,
was the last week of
my three months leave.
And it opened up me
being more present,
as well, to a life
that I knew I was like,
whoa, what is this place
that people are in?
And then I rented a friend's
home in Tahoe for a month.
So I would go up
there on weekends.
And so those were just cool
little things that I did.
But again, I didn't have
to plan a huge trip.
Because I think in
my mind I wasn't
ready to take responsibility
to have a big to-do item,
because I wasn't
mentally equipped,
I don't think, at
that point for that.
Does that answer your question?
That's a good question.
Yeah.
Great.
Well, thanks,
everyone, for coming,
and I will be here
to sign books.
Thank you.